[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now fan corrections this is a segment
where viewers and we've done this a lot
viewers try very hard real viewers look
for mistakes on the show they make a
video they send it in so far we've had
many challengers not one winner
nobody has yet caught me making a
mistake well tonight a fan with the
youtube handle not fps fanboy
says he thinks he caught a mistake he
says it happened during a recent comedy
sketch we did about herman cain
hey conan watching your show the other
night you made a joke about herman cain
and free breadsticks from godfather's
pizza herman cain made the exact same
kind of ads when he was running
godfather's pizza this is your pizza
without a free order of breadsticks
any questions
a little problem with that herman cain
stepped down to ceo from godfather's
pizza in 1996. at that time breadsticks
did not appear on the godfather's pizza
menu nor had they ever appeared nor
would they appear for another five years
and that was after domino's pizza and
pizza had introduced breadsticks
so
you were just clearly wrong on this one
i think i finally got you
well i'm sorry not fps fanboy but you
are dead wrong godfather's pizza did
have bread sticks when herman cain was
ceo you think i'm not telling the truth
check out this message from the man
himself herman cain
are you kidding me of course godfather's
pizza had breadsticks when i was there
just look at this menu from 1993.
you see that
what does it say breadsticks and what
does it say down here at the bottom
copyrights 1993.
looks like i just corrected you
that'll teach you to shoot a video from
60 feet away yeah
right using a video camera that's i
think covered in
what's vaseline with what's wrong with
that
it's like a fisher-price webcam
[Laughter]
anyway the challenge still stands if you
think you spotted an error on our show
reported at teamcoco.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chuck
meat out of the maestro